hello everyone and welcome to this
session of blockchain my name is Sarah
and I'm part of the simply learned team
now let's get started and let's talk
about what is blockchain and why are we
here
let's let's take an example of a money
transaction which we all do generally
now here we have someone who wants to
transfer money from his account to his
partner's account with whom he has done
a trade deal in a typical banking
transaction you will be transferring
money from your account to your
partner's account but something can go
wrong and the money does not get
deposited and gets back to your account
what could be the problem why did that
transaction fail and what went wrong ok
so here we have our Bitcoin assistant to
tell you what could have gone wrong
there could be some technical issues at
the bank which could have caused the
problem the users account got hacked and
it could be very well possible or you
have exceeded the transfer limits for
the day so you can't do the transaction
again now there's a question which the
crash currency will ask and the answer
is that we are talking about Bitcoin and
it is a cryptocurrency so I'm going to
tell you about what is a cryptocurrency
what are the different types of
cryptocurrencies in the market what is a
blockchain how a Bitcoin transaction
works the features of a blockchain and
we will talk about the Walmart problem
what is a cryptocurrency cryptocurrency
is a form of digital currency that can
be used to verify transfer of assets
from one party to another it controls
the addition of new units there is
limited supply and it also provides
secure financial transactions anonymity
of the sender and receiver is maintained
sanity of the transaction is maintained
and all that is done using cryptography
the transactions are safe and secure and
the most important point is they are not
headed by a central authority so that
means that Gasch can go extent and we
might not even need the bank's either
the basic benefit with the evolution of
cryptocurrency has been the low
transaction cost the underlying concept
of having cryptocurrency is the removal
of the intermediaries by virtue of which
it reduces the transaction cost between
the part
because more the middlemen more the cost
gets added on to every transaction now
what are the types of cryptocurrencies
in the market there are several there
are few other popular cryptocurrencies
apart from Bitcoin which have a major
market capitalization and trading share
is like litecoin it helium jet cash -
ripple Manero nem and Stella these are
few to name it but there are hundreds
and thousands of cryptocurrency in the
market which are evolving on a daily
basis what is blotching now bitcoin uses
a technology called blockchain to work
the way does blockchain is a
continuously growing list of records
which are linked to each other so it's a
list of blocks which are getting changed
to each other and are secured using
cryptography each and every block is
digitally signed and hashed now how does
a Bitcoin transaction work let's
consider the same previous situation but
this time let's make the transaction
happen using a Bitcoin now the same
through entities who wants to exchange
money instead of that they will be
exchanging bitcoins but before that they
would have to create a wallet address on
the Bitcoin network and each will be
having their own private and public key
so whenever you want to send a Bitcoin
on the bill on the blockchain network
you will be encrypting the transaction
with your private key and broadcasting
it worldwide for the miners to validate
it miners around the world on the
network will verify the authenticity of
the sender whether the sender has the
right amount of balance to send that
amount and the miner will also validate
the receiver the identity of the
receiver the jen unity of its wallet
address and then it will verify the
sanity of the transaction whether the
transaction can take place on the
network or not if verified the
transaction would be added to a block
which would also contain several other
transactions which are to be aggregated
in that block and then once the block is
verified it will be added to the main
blockchain once this whole process has
been done the miners have verified the
block and verified the entire set of
transactions in that block then the
transaction show the
bitcoins are reduced from the wallet of
the sender and added to the receivers
and this is how the transaction very
similar to the banking transaction which
we saw in our previous slides gets
completed without the intermediaries
like banks now so what makes Bitcoin so
special these are the few primary
features of blockchain it's a publicly
distributed ledger which means everyone
has access to all the record if the user
wants they can access all the records
from the time the blockchain was created
the first block in the blockchain is
called the Genesis block any additions
to the block are permanent and immutable
any change major or minor is recorded
into a new block and cannot be altered
and this is the primary immutability
feature of blockchain there is no
centralized Authority since the ledger
is distributed the ledger cannot be
altered by hacking into a central
authority system like general hacking
incidents happen any change has to be
approved by the majority of the people
in the network and therefore there are
algorithms for proof of consensus
consensus algorithm exists in any
blockchain network where the majority of
the stakeholders have to approve the
transaction block chain can contain
transaction details for assets other
than money like property vehicles
farming products or any asset which you
want to trace in any industry like
supply chain or you want to use digital
assets in retail etc now how does
encryption happens on a typical
blockchain network so whenever a sender
sends initiates a transaction he signs
the transaction using his private key
and all the details pertaining to the
transaction like the receivers address
and the other details of the transaction
are encapsulated and encrypted using the
sender's private key now bitcoin uses
the sha-256 encryption it is the
encryption algorithm which allows you to
create an encrypted output which is very
secure and it is a very popular
encryption algorithm the encrypted
output is then transmitted across the
world and the transit
action after verification by the miners
is added to a block the sha-256 enables
the verification of the authenticity of
the sender and receiver and provides the
strongest security which is highly
impervious to hacks and most importantly
it ensures the anonymity of the users
who have initiated the transaction and
also the receivers who are going to
receive it now let's take a look of a
typical structure of a block in a
blockchain a block contains n number of
transactions which are aggregated by the
miner onto the block now here we are
looking at a block header which has four
attributes previous hash transaction
details the norms and the hash of the
block itself we'll take a look
previous hash the previous hash is the
hash value of the previous block in
their blockchain this is how you are
able to link one block to another as the
current block has the hash of the
previous block transaction details the
field contains the details of the
various transactions which are
aggregated as part of this block nonce
nonce is the random value which is used
to generate a hash value less than the
target designated by the network for
each and every block the value of the
nonce can be changed it's a random value
and every time a nonce value is changed
the hash it takes huge computational
power of the miner to generate the hash
again so that's why miners need huge
computational power and hardware in
order to generate the hash and to guess
the nonce in a stipulated time so that
they can on the reward hash the hash
obtained is a hex value that has both
numbers and letters any change to the
nonce transaction details or previous
hash will completely change the outcome
of the hashing function and that's why
it is said that even if a hacker wants
to try hacking a single block then he
has to change the hash of all the
subsequent blocks and in order to do
that it will take a huge amount of
computational power and time in order to
change the hashes of all the blocks
which are ahead of the hack block so
that makes it literally impossible in
order to hack a blockchain now proof of
work in
Valls several miners around the world
who are using their hardware and
computational algorithm to try and find
the norms value that satisfied certain
predefined conditions regarding the hash
value which has to be less than the
target decided by the network for in
order to verify a block so miners are
continuously working to maintain the
sanity of the network to validate the
transactions and to make sure that there
is no corrupt block which is getting
added to the blockchain
miner in the process of mining gets
rewarded with twelve point five bitcoins
for finding the appropriate nonce first
the reward of twelve point five bitcoins
exist as of today but bitcoins are going
rewarding has been done by huffing
methodology some time back it was 25
bitcoins now it has reduced to twelve
point five Bitcoin and in subsequent
time it will come down to six point to
five as the number of bitcoins in the
network are reducing there is a limited
supply of bitcoins it's capped at
twenty-one million as of today
approximately 18 million bitcoins have
already been mined so there are a
million more bitcoins left the block is
said to be mined once it's added to the
blockchain the person the miner who
finds the norms that satisfy the hash
requirement for the block is awarded the
twelve point five Bitcoin mining reward
the last transaction in every block
assigns 12.5 Bitcoin to the miner as a
reward and this is the only way to
generate new bitcoins there is no other
way the bitcoins are generated in the
network now just to see one real-life
example blockchain isn't only used for
Bitcoin it is also used for supply chain
management supply chain is the biggest
industry in adoption of blockchain
because in most of the supply chain use
cases they have the use case of
provenance and traceability of the asset
which is being moving in the supply
chain so the exact problem for Walmart
was to find the origination of the bad
product in the supply chain when the
products are returned they wanted to
know where the bad products have
originated in their supply chain now in
a typical farming supply chain the
entities which are involved are
deforming the farmers
the logistics and transportation
companies from the farming to
transportation then they are transported
to storage and warehouses where they are
kept and then the distributed through
the distributor and retailer Network
they reach to the customer now there is
a possibility that the product in the
entire supply chain wherever it has
changed hands it could have been made
bad it could have been counterfeited or
compromised so it becomes important for
any supply chain company in order to
know where in the entire supply chain
the product was counterfeited or was
compromised
so using block chain Walmart is able to
determine where the issue with the
product originated they trace the entire
journey of the product wherever it has
change hands the relevant parties and
entities are asked to update the status
the coordinates of the product on the
blockchain network as the blockchain is
an immutable ledger there is no chance
of someone else fiddling with that
information thereby the executives the
management committee is able to trace
the entire journey and proof that where
in the supply chain the product was
fiddled or counterfeited
so you see blockchain apart from Bitcoin
is gonna get adopted across the
industries and it's gonna be there for a
long long time I hope you had a great
learning experience and I'll meet you in
the next session thank you
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simple learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos de nerd up and get certified
click here